radio so I said before we were gonna
look at the just some concrete examples
well what's it worth generally speaking
what does it mean what is a polynomial
okay
well it means you've got this form right
you're gonna have some coefficients some
constant terms okay and they have to be
real numbers right I'm have to be
algebraic numbers actually and you're
multiplying that by some variable raised
to an integer power and you can have a
series of these added together right so
I could have this applies of as many as
you like
now from here is my own my notation
breaks down so you could have way more
than 26 years or we're near 26 letters
so I'm just gonna choose to end it at Z
okay and that's actually going to be a
constant right but rather than write it
just as dead I'm gonna connect it to all
the terms in them that you've got
previously here okay now it's also worth
remembering that each of these things in
here is also its own polynomial okay so
and for some reason I can't get that
meme out of my head which is like your
dog I heard you like do this so I stuck
a polynomial polynomial so give me I
can't remember how it goes after that
anyway what specifically what are each
of these bits and pieces come from
that's our let me get a different color
okay the most important property of this
polynomial used this number right here
the biggest power that you can get okay
this is called the degree it's the
highest power that you find in your
specific Y no no okay so mostly gyms I
guess gave me with like degree one or
degree two what else is important for
you well something like this that number
and this variable start together okay we
call that a turn right that's where
that's why it's called many terms right
there's a whole bunch of that but most
important term is the one with the
degree on right because that's what it's
defined everything else we call that
because it's out the front
we call it the leading
okay okay what else is useful here
well this these clothes of times they're
at the front of each married woman right
well you already know what their core
that's going to be a coefficient and
naturally the most important coefficient
of a polynomial is the one attached to
the leading term which we call the
leading coefficient okay now those are
the bits and pieces to do with this one
more important word apart from all the
reasons that you need to get is a factor
we've been working with yes how would
you define a factor if we think that
like hold on my digits and that kind of
thing right you can play the sentence a
factor is
okay all right all right so when we just
think about numbers right like say 24
okay we would say something is a factor
of 24 if when you do this division okay
what you get at the end is another whole
number right or another way you could
say it is you get a whole number and
there's there are other bits sort of
sitting off on the end if the remainder
is zero okay now because that's to do
with numbers and we're doing pornos here
okay a polynomial factor is a polynomial
that you can divide through and again
just like with our integers over here
okay
it leaves no remainder right okay
to put it one more way right a factor is
something that what's the divide through
what you get at the end allows you to
express a product again with little bits
flying off on the side okay so I can
write this as 24 is 8 by 3 okay with
with no other bits hey over here
that one that would be what a remainder
is